Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie. Thank you everyone that submitted questions for this week's Arrow and Flash Q&A.
I know that a lot of questions about what's going on with Caitlin Snow and all the Arrow questions are really all over the board.
You know, how is Oliver still alive?  What's going on with Ra's al Ghul?  How is it going to tie in with the back half of the season?
So I'll try to get to everything.  Next week is going to be another Vertigo-based episode.
But we also have details on episodes
14 and 15, so I'll talk about that after I get through questions.
Okay, so just careful for spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen them yet as we work our way through questions.  So here we go.
Rafael asks, "what do you think is gonna happen to give Cisco and Caitlin their Vibe and Killer Frost abilities?
I think Dr. Wells was lying when he told the press he wouldn't, or he wasn't trying to turn the particle accelerator back on.
So, there's a couple things that could go on here
Basically what I've seen from Greg Berlanti and the producers is that they just  wanna let Caitlin and Cisco be Caitlin and Cisco for now.
So, no powers Season 1 is what I think is going to happen.
That doesn't mean they won't ever get powers
but I think they're building the Caitlin Snow character out inside this Firestorm arc,
so, once they establish Firestorm, then they'll transition to a more Caitlin-centric storyline.
To answer your question about the particle accelerator,
there's really two ways you could go on that
so, one, he could not need to build another one because he only needed it to create the first Barry Allen.
The other side of that, two, is you could say, 'yeah, he might need to turn it back on to do some cosmic treadmill time travel stuff'
I really have no idea how they're going to explain the time travel.
We'll find out in about Episode 15, that will be, like, the first time we see time travel.
So presumably the Reverse Flash will time travel the same way that the Flash does.
But because Barry won't need the particle accelerator to be "on" to time travel, I don't think the Reverse Flash will need to do that either.
I may have explained it in my Episode 11 video, but if you look at Barry Allen from the perspective of being the originator of the speed force,
it's possible that Harrison Wells only needed to create the particle accelerator to create the Flash.
They might choose to go another route with the way they explain it because the speed force is also, like, another dimension in and of itself.
you can get trapped inside the speed force.
That'd be a really awesome way to leave off the season.
You can let me know if you agree.
Do you want to see the Reverse Flash trap Barry inside the speed force this season?
Next question:  Mark asks, "who do you think will be in the Rouges? Do you think that they'll have people with powers or use tech-based villains?"
Well I think it'll be a combination of both tech and meta-human based abilities
As for the relative composition of the Rouges, I don't think that there's gonna be that many this season
We have Heat Wave, Captain Cold, and now Golden Glider, Captain Cold's sister.
So at least those three.  Pied Piper is kind of a loner so I don't know that he's necessarily gonna team up with the other Rouges this season
But that's a possibility.
Then there's always the possibility that the Reverse Flash could use the Rouges
That wouldn't necessarily mean him joining the Rouges
They could form a temporary alliance
To be honest, though, I'd rather see them use Captain Cold's gun to take down the Reverse Flash
Next question: Bartu asks, "What are Batman and Superman doing? Are they even in this DC Arrow/Flash TV universe?"
Well, yes, they're in the universe, it's just that
because of licensing rights, they're not allowed to mention them on screen.
Specifically by name
Like Clark Kent, Bruce Wayne
The simplest way to look at it is that Bruce Wayne is of a comparable age to Oliver Queen
So if Oliver Queen is going through his initial permutations before he becomes the Emerald Archer, before he joins the Justice League,
Assume that Batman is at a similar stage of development
Or if you really want to nitpick, and say that Bruce Wayne is still gonna join the League of Assassins
at some point, you could say that Bruce has almost gone to Nanda Parbat, like he's not quite there yet.
Just in general terms, assume the entire DC universe exists inside the Arrow-verse
it seems kinda silly but think about it this way:  Arrow isn't so much a comic book show as it's "The Wire"
With a comic book character in it
Someone asked Marc Guggenheim about his favorite TV shows and he said, "The Wire, and Sons of Anarchy"
So don't think of Arrow such much as being a DC show, as being a drama with a couple DC characters in it
So they follow the logic of traditional drama, more than they do comic book logic
it's always hard to explain why they don't have Barry Allen on speed dial all the time
But the simplest answer is that it would ruin all their stories
It's harder to tell human drama when you have unlimited power
That's why it's so hard to get a Superman movie right, so that's why Arrow has stayed away from powers
although they're slowly changing their tune
Next question:  Henbot asks, "Is no one getting rather disturbed by the fact that they're locking up all these people without loos, rights, sunlight, trial or anything."
So yeah, I definitely think that the show's gonna address this
They're trying to do the right thing, but they're still figuring things out
so they're gonna make a lot of mistakes
Let's not forget about the idea of the prison break, too.
If you were the Reverse Flash, and the Flash was one of the only people that could defeat you
How would you deal with him so you could carry out some secret plan and keep him from stopping you?
One easy way to distract him, would be to release all those metahumans at the same time
Team Flash would be so busy dealing with them they probably wouldn't be able to deal with the Reverse Flash
That doesn't mean that's what the Reverse Flash is planning on doing
I think that the Reverse Flash, Harrsion Wells, that is, is going to enter into a Malcolm Merlyn/Oliver situation with Barry at a certain point.
Barry still doesn't know what's going on.
So they're gonna have that moment first, but
I think Harrison will appeal to Barry's emotions
and he'll begrudgingly help him.
Next question:  Nomar asks, "So, did Barry take a peek like Caitlin suggested?"
Well, I kind of think he did, like a little bit, very briefly, but I think he's trying to forget about it
As he said, he's still hung up on Iris, so thinking of Caitlin in a romantic way just isn't on his radar
It's pretty believable that a dude would be pretty dense about that, too.
Just not notice that a girl was into him.
Barry's so busy trying to get faster as the Flash, and deal with Iris, that he doesn't see Caitlin that way.
But yes, he totally sneaked a brief peek.  There is no one that would not have peeked
Next question: Mijan asks, " I actually thought of Killer Croc when they went underground"
Actually the comic book the Flash Season 0 comic book this week, had King Shark in it.
So I think that they're just slowly teasing into the crossbreed metahumans.
when I say that, I mean like genetic experiments
They could also be teasing something going on underneath Central City
Like metahumans crawling around in the sewers
I like that idea too
It would be really cool if Gorilla Grod created Gorilla City in the sewers beneath Central City
Without Team Flash knowing about it
Okay, next question -  so I'm moving into Arrow related stuff now -
Laylla Willow asks, "Still waiting for an explanation on how Oliver's alive again
wasn't he stabbed in the chest? Now we see bandages over his stomach.  Danny saying to Laurel 'you're lucky I don't kill women' and now we see him explaining how he killed Malcolm's wife
and he was all happy about it'"
Okay, so just working down your list
The place that Ra's al Ghul stabbed him was probably, like, in just the right place
Like, Oliver got lucky, plus Katana probably had some really awesome healing skills
I did see some confusion - a lot of people thought that he got stabbed in the heart
he got stabbed on the other side of his chest
and it was really like kinda just below his ribcage
so if he got stabbed in any critical organs
it was one of his lungs.  And you could still survive with just one lung working
Usually when they lay things down in the writers' room, they make complete sense
but by the time it gets filmed, edited, and it airs on television,
it's changed a whole bunch.
So if there's any inconsistencies, it's just a function of the production process
As for the Brick thing, not killing women, you can look at it a couple different ways
One, he could not be killing women anymore
like maybe he used to kill women and he created that policy after he became the Brick that we see right now
or option 2,
he could be an unreliable narrator. He could just be lying through his teeth.
Next question:  GorillaM asks, "Who do you think will be resurrected in the Lazarus pit.  My money's on Tommy or Ra's al Ghul"
So Arrow actually, they did build a Lazarus Pit set
in episode 4, we see him getting out of like, a hot tub looking thing, I don't know if that's the Lazarus Pit
they were talking about.  Let's just assume that it is for a minute
because they said they made a lot of hot tub time machine jokes
I feel like the biggest WTF they could do that would be really awesome way to end the season is if
someone like Merlyn ends up killing Ra's Al Ghul
and then Nissa dumps his body in the Lazarus Pit
Regardless of how Ra's Al Ghul is dealt with, if anyone's gonna get to use it
it's gonna be him
Next question:  Felix Boettcher asks, "My favorite scene was when Lance and Arsenal were talking and Lance was like, 'I'm not stupid, I know it's you, Roy'"
Yeah, that was really funny.  I feel like that's just teeing up the Black Canary reveal
He's going to figure out that Laurel is the Black Canary.
It's just a way for the TV Series to tell us that Quentin is a very smart person, he's a good detective
So if he wants to learn someone's secret identity, he's going to learn it
I feel like the line gets drawn at the Arrow's identity, though
In the comics, there have been various points where Jim Gordon seems like he knows who Batman is
and he probably does, but openly, he says he doesn't want to know.
Next question:  Potatochip asks, "When are they going to bring in Oliver's son that he doesn't know about?"
There's a couple ways to think about this.  They could bring him on as part of a family arc in a future season
I feel like this season's already too crowded with characters
so bringing him on probably wouldn't help.
Option 2, is for like another Flarrrow reveal, like the Arrow/Flash crossover in following seasons, like seasons 4, 5, 6, you know, whatever
until they're ready to actually bring the kid on in a major arc
Next question:  Bryan asks, "Is there going to be another Arrow/Flash crossover?"
So this season, episode 18 is going to be an A.T.O.M./Flash crossover
So, kind of Flash/Arrow crossover
but it'll be very A.T.O.M. specific
The big crossover that you might be talking about, the Flarrow crossover, they're gonna do that every year
It'll come before the mid season finale every year
They'll keep doing that every year as long as the Arrow and the Flash are on air.
The CW just said it was the most successful thing that they ever did
so, yeah, definitely lots more Arrow/Flash crossovers, but it's only gonna be once-a-season kind of thing
Next question:  Pyonz asks, "What do you think Slade's significance is this season?  Isn't he supposed to make an appearance in episode 14?"
I'd really like to see a Slade vs. Ra's Al Ghul fight"
So Slade is going to be in an island episode that's going to be episode 14, The Return
I'm going to read the synopsis for Episode 14 right now
Malcolm puts Oliver and Thea in a dangerous situation that lands them on Lian Yu with Oliver's former enemy, Deathstroke.
So we don't know what that dangerous situation that Merlyn throws them in.  I'm just guessing that Slade gets out
and they end up fighting a little bit, and Slade gets away
and since we've been talking about the A.T.O.M. suit a lot and the Nanda Parbat, here's actually the description for Episode 15
If you guys haven't read it,
"Malcolm is captured by Ra's Al Ghul and taken to Nanda Parbat.
Because of his love for Thea, Oliver considers saving Merlyn.
Then back in Starling, Ray is obsessed with finishing his A.T.O.M suit so he can save the city.
But Felicity fears he's heading down the same path as Oliver, and tries to pull him out of the lab.
I know that sounds kind of opaque, but it is something to get really excited about.
Thank you so much everyone that submitted questions.
These are always a ton of fun to do.
Don't forget, lots of big stuff happening this weekend
So we have a Game of Thrones special
Walking Dead is coming back, be sure to subscribe to get all that stuff
I'm going to try and do some Game play for the Game of Thrones Telltale game on my Twitch channel this weekend, too, maybe tomorrow
Just in case you guys haven't seen them yet, you can click here for this week's Flash episode and here for this week's Arrow episode.
Thank you so much for watching so I'll see you guys this weekend. High Fives!
<<music>>